j'ai souhaité ensuite par l'ensemble des
forces politiques pour avoir un dialogue
de vérité car au delà de l'explosion
nous savons que la crise ici est grave
elle implique une responsabilité
historique des dirigeants en place
c'est une crise politique morale
économique et financière dans la
première victime et le peuple libanais
et elle impose des réactions extrêmement
rapide et donc pour moi cette visite est
aussi l'occasion d'un dialogue de
franchise d'une exigence aussi à l'égard
des forces politiques et des
institutions libanaises août est d'abord
aujourd'hui la priorité c'est de l'aide
le soutien à la population sans
conditions mais c'est l'exigence que la
france porte depuis des mois pour ne pas
dire des années en effet de réformes
indispensables dans certains secteurs où
c'est l'énergie les marchés publics la
lutte contre la corruption
si ces réformes ne sont pas faites le
liban continuera de s'enfoncer
c'est un autre dialogue que nous devons
avoir et que je souhaite aussi mener
aujourd'hui